let's hit a call right here this came in
boom boom for your diet EO live free to
die that's what New Hampshire's coming
with new we all we all rock together
with that [ __ ] believe it
live free or die you heard him and
that's this your boy Rico coming out and
out of New Hampshire calling in about
that state's war
tell me more reek is Rico and let me
just say this we're gonna call in saying
that their state isn't gonna win the war
what kind of what kind of mentality is
that to go into war with that [ __ ]
brutal well they got some kind a state's
out there you know what is it somewhere
is the land of lovers where is that
place well look you try to hug a
[ __ ] with a machete Gang Gang
you gonna lose that hug Moore and for
anyone to call up and say that state
isn't gonna take I don't even know what
that's about
well they have the guy from Maine the
call that I'm you know onward sorry
interrupting you on word Rico have no
you have no no passion no love your
infestation bro it's small enough where
we all kind of know each other we got
those crazy [ __ ] down Seabrook
down on the coast
what do first of all small enough we all
know each other
dude this ain't a quinceanera man this
is a war you can't be you know I'm
saying you can't be like Oh Randy just
got here that [ __ ] can't happen on the
battlefield
this ain't a pickup game you know you
can't be down there and be like Oh who's
who we dressing out for this man come on
man Seabrook you said we got it oh we
got those Mad Hatter's down would you
say here let me listen to this one more
time let's hear this all kind of know
each other we got those crazy
[ __ ] down he look down with
Seabrook penitentiary Dennis it what
does Seabrook it sound like a rich
people haha homestead area on the water
what you got rich people and a Seabrooke
what they do and driving sobs you can't
what are they gonna do throw fancy
a jewelry of people I'm saying you can't
you can't [ __ ] you can't beat you
can't beat somebody to death with it
with a wristlet you know widow with a 14
karat gold candelabra the Saint clue
this include the board game you got to
come with something real let's hear more
down on the coast we got like 13 miles
of shoreline we got those Hampton Beach
critters we got the mountains we get
what mountains dude the mountains of New
Hampshire what do y'all got man I look
up this [ __ ] cat [ __ ] claim right now
mountains of New Hampshire what do ya'll
have just say right here Mount
Washington 6,200 feet [ __ ] listen Rico
uncle Rico could throw a football over
that thing that ain't nothing you got
Loon Mountain 3,000 feet do it all
backflip off of that [ __ ] what else
y'all got nothing Wildcat Mountain I'm
looking at the picture the first picture
of it right here on uh on Google Images
you got too thick frosty whites hanging
out by a sign say toilets this way man
this ain't no [ __ ] y'all ain't got an
army bruh this do got man tits right
there he got tits hanging off his elbows
he got them elbow titties boy come on
man I'm gonna let you go a little more
let's hear more Rico an alien border
okay now you got the Canadian border
that's huge we get those wild boys out
in Keene State College we got Plymouth
State College Dartmouth we have them
drawing up schematics New Hampshire is
taking this [ __ ] it's not I'm in the
artists it's not even close not even
close to what you got people drawn up
schematics
what is that ski Maddox dude this thing
this ain't the Iditarod brother
this ain't cross-country ski and man
this is war you got people out of Keene
State do you how bad of colleges if they
say it's Kane come on dude Keene State
come on there's not a lot of us but
we're here
we're here that's your motto dude that's
sound like a shitty motel chain we're
here oh we're we're gonna take over
Maine quick oh yeah
yeah oh I believe that dude Maine ain't
nothing bro Maine up there eating
poisonous berries dude you know it's a
bunch of stoners acting like they know
what the wilderness is about 48 hours
outside rather be in that freezing cold
rain accidentally eat a poisonous berry
Gang Gang done call of the wild let's
hear more
there's townships in Maine that are not
incorporated into the United States
that's how just making it is so we're
gonna move in there take over Maine
quick and we're just kind of going to
kind of lay low that quick take over
Maine thing too keen and lay low lay low
right yeah I'm gonna be tired
lay low y'all hop double syrup New
Hampshire man look I respect it but I
don't see any chance bro no Hampshire
you got no Hampshire dude the coolest
thing y'all will have is a flag that
have a HAMP on it maybe Gang Gang good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one